so what are some tips that you can share
in terms of
not finding reasons to get up from the
desk and and making excuses because i'm
sure
that might have been easier knowing that
there was this ticking clock yeah when
when there's a deadline it's a lot
easier to force yourself to just stay
there
you know you know how many pages you
have to write on average each day to
to be finished by the the date they set
for you
and if you're not making that quota
you know you're screwing up and someday
you're going to be up 24 hours straight
trying to make up for it so it's it's uh
when you've got a deadline it's a lot
easier to
to discipline yourself at the same time
my in my experience uh screenwriting is
80 percent
surfing the web doing dishes walking the
dog
all the while hopefully you're thinking
about what you're going to be writing
and then 20 of the time you're actually
typing
away so speaking of that when you are
your own
band leader for lack of a better word
what are some tips that you can use to
keep yourself again in that chair or is
it all part of this process of just
observation you know
honestly i i think it's a it's a
double-edged sword because you can
justify
a lot of goofing off during the writing
process as letting the creative juices
flow and build and letting your mind
wander a bit you know the truth is
story not so much storytelling but story
creating
happens in the subconscious
and sometimes if you just sit there and
you stare at a computer screen or you
stare at a blank piece of paper
waiting for words to come
it's a more forced artificial process
whereas you know
sitting in a park
watching people interact you might get
an idea for something
on the other hand you can waste way too
much time doing that so it's a
double-edged sword and you have to find
a way
to to discipline yourself and you know
that's going to be different for
everybody
the way i do it is to set myself a page
quote i have to write a certain number
of pages each day
and if i've wasted time on the internet
or in pointless facebook debates which
seem to occupy an increasingly
large amount of time
um
you know i don't let myself get up i
don't let myself go to bed or whatever
i don't leave the computer
until i've reached that quota
so that's that that's really the only
way for me that's uh
that's really proven to be effective
because otherwise you know i'll write
one good little bit
and i'll be all proud of myself
and then i'll go do something else and
at the end of the day i discovered that
well that was a good bit but it was only
half a page and now i have 10 pages to
write tomorrow instead of five
so so keeping to a daily quota is really
something that's been effective for me
are you a harsh task master for yourself
are you sort of like one of these
lenient parents real gentle with
yourself and
again it depends on whether i'm i'm
writing on deadline
if i have a deadline and i know when
something has to be done and i'm it's a
paying job
i'm a pretty harsh taskmaster
when i'm writing a spec script for
myself
i tend to go a bit easier on myself on
the theory that
creativity is what's most important here
i'm not on deadline and i don't need to
meet somebody else's uh schedule
and i should just let it flow but again
that's you know that's really just
self-justification and
there's a huge amount i think there's a
huge amount of laziness
involved in being a screenwriter to be
honest with you
you